[Music]
what is that we're gonna put a mine so
there's a giant lizard in my face so
what is this thing
this guy is a black-throated monitor
lizard you can come around here why
don't I he looked he looks terrifying
okay and the fact of the matter is is
that these guys actually were finding
have a kind of venom venomous lizards
believe it or not now would I be holding
him if it was a venom that could hurt me
no so we don't have to worry about that
but if I was his prey small mammals
birds things like that in Africa then I
would want to be afraid look at that I
miss it it's in the in the Thao and the
mouth or the way I have to be where it's
in the mouth you can actually if you
want to grab the back end here just grab
them underneath the tail right
underneath here okay he's getting angry
and then where else it's the show where
right die it's the show where every day
between the front two legs just like
that that's perfect that's perfect this
is my ladies gonna try to eat you see so
there you go this black leopard monitor
again these guys live in Africa he's
beautiful beautiful but very powerfully
strong lizards yeah he's really strong
let me know if you want to rescue here
well I don't know how okay now he's
trying to get his head back around to my
face
yeah you know what he's actually to eat
it and he's destroying my suit yeah I've
been calmer and more happy I don't want
your stupid
just let monitor lizzard you got it oh
this that's my lizard yeah you know what
monitor lizard his animus he's actually
calmer in your arms than he is in mine
well I just injected him so it's a serum
I use on gas sometimes I'm in there
rowdy
because you smell like buttered no okay
we better take this fella away if you
can get it mom I can get them off okay I
just want to he seems to not want out
whoa okay easy with the head the head
coming my way all right all right all
right last but not least
okay we've lost okay last but not least
this guy is a giant white pelican yeah
that's the easiest guess I heard you
want to feed him
yeah you're just gonna I'll do it the
first one and you can watch me you just
want to get his attention we're gonna go
slice up in the air and you see this
immediate need a big pouch under there
let him swallow that one down he's gonna
swallow that yeah he'll swallow that
down hold that house meet her there how
long before he swallows it he's holding
it in the mouth you know and he might be
kind of like hoarding it for later so
see you have a brother like that he
keeps
my brother Neil keeps food in his face
for years at a time let's see I think
he's gone maybe he's gonna die and he's
doing something he's swallowing watch it
did you see what he did he flipped it so
it went down headfirst
ah what a pig yeah
Oh Mike you could imagine if it was I'm
sorry I don't mean to interrupt you but
that was insane yeah
does the Pelican now not have to eat
again for a long time now actually you
know birds are warm-blooded like mammals
like people so we have to like
constantly eat to keep our body
temperature up like that lizard we just
had yeah would only eat you know once or
twice a week because it doesn't have a
really fast metabolism first so I do
this a couple times down on two three
this is fantastic I could not have made
it easier he actually can fly so he
might actually decide to take off but
what was it people the crowd have fish
in their pockets which is often a
distraction
omit communicate pack doll lead I paw
long towel Dolce Hall thumb bow and the
bird is literally turning its back to
the audience never a good sign
[Laughter]